in 1861 i enlisted in the war of the
rebellion
at warsaw in benton county missouri
under colonel o'kane
then a captain we went to cold calf
fought the dutch and cleaned them out
completely
lost only seven of our men with more
than 250 of the dutch kills
no prisoners were taken on either side
from there we went to springfield
missouri where we had the battle of
wilson creek
where general isle was killed on the
10th of august
the bravest man i ever saw was general
land
after he was completely surrounded and
pulled off his horse
he picked up rocks and fought the
thousands of men
around him he struck
will morgan in the face of the rock and
john morgan shut into the lower back and
horsepower
[Music]
how old are you 84 84 he was in the
famed
same war same general from the same
general general price
that's good fine old man too good man
good man he was yes he was and he's
there
to
fine we're having a good time enjoying
enjoying ourselves very much
had a good dinner
you